le gouvernement accélère l'alluré pour
limiter le trou de la sécu au centre des
préoccupations le fameux trou toujours
aussi énorme
la situation est catastrophique le trou
de la sécu ne cesse de se creuser en
voilà un trou dont il est bien difficile
de se dépêtrer des décennies qu'on nous
en parle
alors ça méritait bien une petite
explication je fais les trous des p'tits
trous ans quand les petits trous de
petites ou le petit trou tout le trou de
la sécu autrement dit la dette sociale
c'est l'ensemble des déficits cumulés
par la sécurité sociale depuis sa
création soit depuis plus de 70 ans
double album et et des déficits il y en
a eu
regardez entre 1998 et 2010 8 par
exemple seuls trois années ont affiché
un excédent est alors que les comptes de
la sécu s'approchait de l'équilibré en
les prévisions pour 2020 ne sont pas
très bonnes avec un déficit estimé à
11,3 milliards d'euros
[Musique]
et pourtant plusieurs ministres ont
tenté de leur boucher ce trou de la sécu
tous la pelle à la main armée d'une
bonne dose d'optimisme
florilège j'ai très bon espoir sur les
bâches que j'ai dit que nous
parviendrons à notre objectif à la fin
le travail vous sauvez finit toujours
par payer
manifestement c'est raté c'est à nous
désormais de sauver la sécurité sociale
de la déroute dans laquelle elle risque
de s'enfoncer raté notre politique
consiste précisément à inverser cette
évolution il n'a que trop duré raté raté
raté et peut dire que le trou de la sécu
parce que c'est comme cela que parle les
français le trou de la sécu il est
derrière nous
raté aussi pour marisol touraine
pas si facile donc de leur boucher ce
trou de la sécu le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe l'annoncé pour 2019
une promesse finalement repoussé à 2023
ya de quoi de quoi prendre un flingue
faire un tour
[Musique]